مع نهايه عام واقترابعه من جديد الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا بين مد وجزر جبهات
تشتعل واخرى تنطفئ ولا تلوح في الافق حتى
الان على الاقل بوادر حلل سياسي
اذا كانت العاصمه تركيا يفعشيه الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير شباط الماضي يوما
بلاعي شراره الحرب
عاشته اوكرانيا وما هي الا ساعات حتى كان
القصف
لقد حانت ساعه الصفر الروس يشنون حربهم في
الاتجاهات كافه والقصف يشمل قياف وضواحيها
والجيش الاوكراني ينخرط في القتال فتحت
ابواب التجنيد ومنع السفر للذكور من عمر
ال 18 حتى 60
سعه القوات الروسيه الى تطويق كاف من
الشرق والغرب لكن الوصول الى قلب العاصمه
ظل متعثرا الثاني من ابريل نيسان القوات
الروسيه تنسحب من مشارك المدينه تكرر مشهد
الانسحاب الروسي على اكثر من جبهه من
جزيره الافعى في البحر الاسود مرورا بخارف
شرقا وصولا الى ميكولاي وغير سون جنبا هذه
خير شون احدى جبهات المواجهه الاعلى في
الجنوب الاوكراني من هنا دخل الروسو الى
المدينه في بدايه الحرب ومن هنا خرجوا على
واقع ضربات اوكرانيه استمرت تسعه اشهر
مطر وخيرسون الذي سيطر عليه الروس تحول
الى اطلال قصف الاوكرانيون التجمعات
الروسيه فيه نحو 30 مره وتحول مدرجه الى
مقبره للطائرات
يقول الاوكرانيون ان الدعم العسكريه
الغربيه والامريكي غير المعادله ودفع
الروس الى التركيز على مناطق الدوباس
القريبه من روسيا امريكا
تبيعات ثقيله خلفتها الحرب يصعب انتم حا
من الذاكره فموجات النزوح تواصلت وعداد
الضحايا لم يتوقف والخراب والدمار استوطنا
في طول البلاد وعرضها لكن البعض فضل
العوده والبناء واسترجاع ما فقد انا طولي
احد اولئك
بهذا قصفه منزلي كل مكان كل شيء تضرر
لكننا لن نستسلم سنبني ما دمرته الحرب على
وقع استمرار الحرب تحولت كيف الى قبله
دبلوماسيه لقاده اوروبيين وغربيين غدت
اوكرانيا في نظري كثيرين خط دفاعا اول عن
الناتو والغرب لكن اطاله امد الحرب اثقل
كاهل العاصمه فالبنيه التحتيه عرضه للقذف
الروسي المتواصل والسكان يتجرعون مراره
انقطاع الخدمات الاساسيه
انها الحرب
وتداعيتها
الجزيره كيف